this is you there's another game out on
in these streets on the same day that
infinite wealth was going on you could
set me up yeah well look it's infinite
wealth time let's see sh didn't I have
oh no I do currently let's refresh
though currently sitting at an 89
Metacritic and um again came out the
same day as Tekken 8 huge reviews a lot
of people saying a lot of positive stuff
this is the evolution of the like a
dragon series um ter based now jrpg and
of course Ichiban kazaka the main
protagonist was introduced and then we
had like a dragon gting which kind of
gave you the backstory for kiru and now
the team up in Hawaii so to speak but uh
a different different vibe in the
beginning so I want you to get into what
what You' played so far you know what
your thoughts on like a dragon infinite
wealth as a person who correct for I got
you into the series with like a dragon
the first one so this is now your second
one so what's your fear what's the
vibe I really you know first off I want
to be transparent I didn't play like the
the the game between like a dragon and
this the what was it called the man who
erased his name like a dragon dragon
yeah well I I I forgot that name so
you know I went into this just with the
knowledge of like a dragon and I didn't
feel like I needed that so far no I I'm
only probably six hours in okay okay so
I probably need to go on I do think this
game is slow out the gate for some
reason and I don't think it's as bad on
people that watched and and played like
a dragon but if you're if this is your
first game into the franchise I think
you're going to like it less because
it's a lot of EAS eggs and like fan
service for the beginning cuz you're in
the same area from like a dragon and you
know you're getting a lot of that oh I
remember this place I remember that I
remember these characters but if you
have none of that knowledge you'll be
like are we really on this dude with
this date like really like like and it
shows you again how like how out of
touch ichib Bon yo has and always will
be bro he's such a goofball I love it
yeah and what what I like is like it uh
ichib Bon's always
like a dragon was everyone is in the
railroad ichon like he's literally like
a mental breakdown and he his
imagination he'll like see a sword or
people will transform and what I love
how they handled the conversation in the
story is the rest is like this dude's
lost his mind
go like at the beginning when you
finally get to that point again and
they're like we got to get the bat out
and he he's just starts saying he's like
they transformed he's like oh and then
the people with you oh yeah that
happened last time just go with it he's
crazy it's fine so for clarity ichan
when you play the game when you're
fighting in battles he visualiz his
favorite game is Dragon Quest so he
visualizes you see it through his eyes
as if everybody's these evil monsters
and crazy characters and stuff like that
sometime and what it is is yeah it is a
it is a a modern game that is the only
way I've seen pull a fantasy Style
without breaking the modern play and
it's crazy how they do it like Ichibon
is like he kind of belongs in a stray
jacket some way like he he really does
he's literally lost his mind like he he
sees he sees like at the beginning of a
fight they'll transform into other stuff
and ichib Bon's the only person seeing
all of this yes the rest of it like you
don't know what you're talking about fam
and since you're playing through ichib
Bon's point of view you're seeing it MH
and but no one else is and what I like
is they acknowledge he's crazy no just
go with it it's cool like yes that's
what makes it fun he's like a goofy
version of old boy like he's been locked
up forever he comes out like he's all
back his mind is messed up and he
doesn't realize it it's no it's not it's
not that the prison thing it's just that
he he's such a he's like this dreamer
gra gol lucky try to I'm he's and and on
top of that I view the world like a
video game
okay so he literally sees the world that
way yes okay and what's funny is like
the first one you come across like this
this bat that's in the ground and you'll
sit there and you you go up to it and
like the other two can't lift it and
then he's the only one that lifts it and
that becomes ichib Bon's main weapon
throughout the game a bat and what's
funny is like it's just crazy I've never
seen a game that kind of has like that
final fantasy fantasy era M but there
they this game is clearly in modern era
but what happens is you're playing it
through someone that's pretty much gone
crazy and he sees all these things and
then everyone's just with it yes oh no
that's that's how it goes and like every
time they do a move that would not be
realistic in the world they acknowledge
that that's ich Bond it's good we just
go with it like yeah it's like list with
breaking the wall on certain things it's
absolutely hilarious and your Point like
the real real world situations that's
going on dudes got to get dudes got laid
off dudes get job situations is going
it's just crazy it's a crazy but
continue so so where you at with then as
far as the combat and did you you you in
Hawaii yet yes I'm in Hawai okay you are
you you met the you met the homie yet K
you the te- up went down yet no no not
yet not yet I I I've met a couple people
uh I almost got robbed oh you got robbed
you touchdown oh no yeah almost got
robbed it's it's it's interesting like
right now I don't have the other people
so I'm kind of curious on like his
imination what's going to happen when he
runs into the newer people and and like
are they going to have more of a back
and forth because if you guys remember
in the first one like it was a minute
before they accepted ich Bond's just
crazy yes they're like oh I don't know
what you're talking about ich Bond so
I'm kind of curious how they're going to
handle that happening again no that what
about the fighting system the mini games
they've improved it in every every
aspect now if if they're around each
other they'll they'll attack each other
as well you could hit people in the
buildings uh they they have definitely
you know improved this game on every
aspect Danny Pat no spoilers we got you
Daddy we ain't spoiling we ain't
spoiling we good no I got you and then
um I was going to say Obviously the
comat the turn based on so right now you
got like a party with three four in in
your joint or just it ichy still right
now in your just it well I'm not going
to I do have other people in my party
but I don't want to go into that because
that would be spoiling now how we
feeling about Hawaii as the setting so
far like you feeling it's a nice I don't
think I've played enough that I can
really give like I literally just got
there I got you yeah I'm in the same boy
I mean I'm probably way earlier than you
I didn't get a chance I said playing so
Dam much damn Tekken but um and both my
favorite games drop on the same day but
we but I gotta say man I it's not often
that you have two games you're so
anticipating and they both hit it out
the park man like some sometimes man one
of them fails you yeah no for facts it
usually never works out you know
especially you know these type of games
Tekken being a hardcore you know
fighting games sometimes the fighting
games don't pop off for get that and
then with you know like a dragon as much
as I love it you know Yakuza
historically has kind of been this good
series but kind of Niche and not that
critical in claim but when my man came
ichon kazak they changed the sister to
turnbas JLG it's so good to see the
critical reception that it's now
receiving and the yo they marketing is
crazy right now that's why like when
people try to clarify oh you know this
is why Final Fantasy went away from turn
base it's like but every modern turn
base that actually took it to the next
level is all rating High they're all
selling well you got Persona the what
with Persona 5 and Royale was like an 88
plus this game's an 89 the previous one
did well too so it's just like don't
give me that like they they wanted to
get as many people possible playing and
now uh you know games like 16 happen you
know that that's more of an action game
than RPG so yeah speak speaking of quick
marketing I'm going to change the
subject for a second did y'all see the
the Drone uh Tekken a joint Tekken a
over London Bridge how did they even do
that I have no idea that was crazy that
was bu I have no idea I saw it on jez's
time I'm like is this real like this
CRA insane was insane yeah no I get you
I mean then you know obviously like a
dragon's Market has been crazy T going
over they got Drew get obviously the
Lords are part of it you know what I'm
saying see some of us on that you see me
on that but um yeah it's just good to
see to to your point like the marketing
for these type of and then now they're
getting the critical success now I want
to see if this actually translates to
sales that's going to be big to see if
it actually you know because I know like
a dragon really did well I remember rgg
was very impressed with how it did so to
see how it is but go ahead add I'll let
you finish I'm hoping that it did well
and it continues to do well because you
know how like oh this is turnbas we
switching the combat yeah you know we're
not going to have our expectations be as
high as we normally would for a game
like this so I'm hoping that you know
just because the first game did well
they now we want triple hold on we want
triple this one the chat come for they
don't like my listen I've made me and
kiru cool after playing um the manh raac
so the kiru slander is has calmed down
but we not going to do the Ichibon sler
saying that when my man came the game
actually sold we we're going to put
respect on ichiban's name as far as
popularity and Mass Appeal to this
franchise that wasn't selling your man
was the leader so I feel you Mr to
opinionated and what's his name rig
shower the original shower posy 86 I see
you I see you gang gang and all that but
put respect on ich B for taking the
series look forward with the sale
I always got to get him a little
bit
continue you good you muted add you
muted can't hear you yeah I hear you oh
there you go now now I can he yeah it's
good man I'm really enjoying it so far
I've been streaming on the addict Arena
channel uh so you know U really good man
so far uh solid
experience I'm this and Final Fantasy
rebirth were probably my two most Anti
ipated games this year and about like
those are the three like trifectas that
I really really want to play this year
and it seems like you know hopefully all
of them you know deliver yeah give it a
shot man this this SCS really cool I
want s will we ever be getting you in
the world of yakaza one day may maybe a
little little like a dragon infinite I
mean the fact that is is term based and
it's you know obviously Mission based
like RPG is something that I could
consider being able to play on the rck
and like it coming back and forth so
maybe I didn't I bought the first one at
the launch of the Xbox series X I'm like
I'm play this and that it stayed right
there bro oh that was a TI you supposed
to play it wasn't no real Halo infin
wasn't no major launch but you know what
it was like everything like at that
point everything started changing for me
like I had to work more and it was like
same happened with me like again I had
my issues with ff7 remake you know
Barrett's voice and stuff like that but
all overall love that game um I had to
stop playing it because I just I I
didn't have the time anymore I feel you
and then I'm so far in that you know
that original playthrough on Playstation
I'm like man like got I want to even
though I you I could pick it up on PC
and and start it again on the on the rag
or whatever I'm like damn I'm so far in
that game I just need to find time to go
in and and you know take the half hour
it's going to take me to relearn
everything or whatever um but I don't
want to start all over again I got you
but this um I just again I I heard so
many good things about this second one
like yo it takes the the formula it
fixes a you know a lot of things that
people had issues with in the first one
uh you know the same you know level of
comedy and and people really love this
termbase right because the original was
just a kind of a beat him up it was kind
of in a lot of ways the evolution of
shenmu right yes yes action represents
yeah so to turn it into a straight up
RPG and for it to be received as well as
as it has been and to come come off of a
character with the history and pedigree
of a kiru and to be able to put another
leading person into that role it's a
hard thing it's a hard thing to do and
for that character to be endearing and
be considered its own thing and and not
a lesser than thing is is I Sega sega's
they hot right now they're doing their
thing so um yeah hopefully one day I I
will get to play it because I think I I
would definitely enjoy it the comedy
aspects of it the first one when I saw
the men in the diapers I'm like what the
hell's going on
what is this summons pound mates hit the
phone and wild people come out to wild
people come out and I heard this a Crazy
Taxi Driver in this his super is driving
you driving you to you want to throw up
or something like that almost killing
you with the Uber then they got the mini
games like a Crazy Taxi on a bike
delivering pizza to people they like
sega's going on out vers Fighters 3 in
it is a mini game like this is that's
right that's right you have all you have
all Sega games in there as well right
it's so Sega like is shout out to sh Sol
you would love it because it's the
spiritual successor of how you know no
disrespect to the OG us Suzuki you got
be in the video games I love you I'm not
trying to SL you my man I met you once
you a hero but we got to admit like
where at was that like it has an evolved
sense yakaza is truly what rgg is doing
this is future how it's supposed to be
and and they and they understand how to
do a city and moving things it's just so
so well done so yeah to see adct getting
into it it's super cool and the last
thing I'll say it's hilarious but this
game will have some of the most
heartfelt moments when you go yo the
Yakuza Series has that type of energy
it's this nice balance of silly goofy
but also serious martial artarts Gangsta
Yakuza stuff going on so yeah so I'm I'm
with addict man I gotta catch up to him
he he ahead of me right now heead of me
but any other fin words um addict D Yak
is infinite wealth no I I think I'm
going to uh I was going to stream today
but I think I'm going to focus on other
stuff today okay so I'll be streaming
tomorrow and I'll probably stream it no
doubt like a dragon infin we in